で すべて知りたいと思っている一般の我々よりは
このお釈迦様の時代の人々というのはかなり桁違いの能力があったということで
だから今ちょこっと前説明したのは
このある一部の修行者たちが神様のことをどう語ったのかという
勝手に語ったわけでもない
でも彼らがあまりこの聖書とかないんです
自分が見たことを言っただけで
またたくさんなります
そのあの前引用した経典
長部経典の第一 そちらであるこの六十二の超越した哲学も
結局は時間論 空間論 実体論なんですよ
まあ難しいんだったらさっさと飛ばします
自分の力で全てを知ることに挑戦した宗教家たちが
時間 空間 実体という 3つの立場で自分たちが発見した事実データを評価した
評価して評価して結論に至ったのです
例えば 瞑想して過去何十光年やら一光年一行といったら
そのデータを時間的に
あるいは空間的に あるいは実体として考えて結論を作るんです
基準にする時間の長さ
空間の広さによって哲学は異なっていくんですよ
だから今前言った例で見ると
あの 一番最初に生まれた神が自分の過去を見てないんですよ
自分に体が現れた時から
俺が最初に生まれたんだと
それで時間的に短いでしょ
取ったところは もっと過去を見たら
いえ 別なところにいたんだよということがわかるでしょうし
そうすると別な生命もいたんだよとわかるでしょうしね
そうすると私が世界を作ったという考え方はなくなる
それで人間になって瞑想した人でも
自分の前の生まれだけではなくて
もっともっと遡っていったならば
だからどれぐらい時間取るのかというね
ことによって哲学が変わってしまいます
だから危ない 良くないんで
時間論というのはね 空間の場合も同じですよ
宇宙を見ようかなと思って
ある程度で宇宙を見たら
それ以上まるっきり見なかったならば
宇宙はこれまでだと 宇宙は有限であると言っちゃう
そういう哲学あるんです
六十二の中で あるいはもっともっと見ようかなと思ったら
もう見られなくなった人がなんですけど
あるいは推測する やっぱりもっと見ればもっとあるかも
だから無限やと言ったりする
それは空間的なもの そこで過去を見てみて
自分があちらでいた こちらでいた
あちらでいたとなってくると
あ 自分というものがいるんだぞという実体論になるんです
時間的に過去を遡っても
さらに過去があるでしょ
空間もの場合も さらに広い空間があることになる
納得できる結論は成り立たないんです
この微妙なポイント みんな忘れちゃったんです
時間論 空間論に達すと結論がないと
ブッダはこれはもうよく分かったんですね
それで冗談の例でわかりますよ
時間論 空間論のおかしさ
犬は哲学するならば 人間
いわゆる飼い主は不死で万能だろうと思うでしょ
犬から見ればね 自分より先に見ましたし
自分は先に年取ってボロボロになって死んじゃうし
そこで自分が全くも飼い主にすがって従って機嫌をとって生活しなくちゃいけないでしょ
やっぱりこの人は永遠で洗脳やと
犬は思う それ 犬の時間論と空間論なんでしょ
でも本当は我々はそうじゃない
でも犬にはそれしか知識はありません
ガラパゴス島のいるゾウガメなら
人間は短い命よ 人間の短い命を楽しむでしょう
犬は人間の命を見て はあ
神様 神様じゃなくて不死だなとかね
思っちゃうし ガラパゴスゴリラゾウガメはなんてなんて短いでしょうかね
あなた方の寿命はと思っちゃうんです
だからガラパゴス島のゾウガメの時間範囲と犬の時間範囲は違うでしょ
だからどちらでも結論しちゃうとダメなんです
そんなもんです 人間もゾウガメの寿命は正確にはわからない
時間論にかかると一部しかわからないんですよ
ここにいて周りを見ると地球が平らですが
まあ我々を見ると地球は平らでしょ
本気で見てください 平らです
宇宙から見ると丸い それも空間論でしょ
こちらにいると小さな空間を見るんだからね
宇宙にいるともっと大きい空間を見るんだだから
空間論にしても一部しか見えない
だからまあちょこっと
これはゾウガメなんです
これは本当に 名前はハリエット
ハリエットですよ これはチャールズダーウィンさんが見て持ってきたものだと思っているゾウガメで
いまだに生きてますよ
オーストラリアのクイーンズランドというところにまだまだいる
チャールズダーウィンはとっくに前に死んじゃったんだけど
それで寿命なんですけど
ガラパゴスのカメはね
あの百二十から二百年かもっとかというふうに推測だけ
わからない なんでわからないのかと
研究者が先に死んじゃいますからね
ゾウガメの研究に行くときでもね
まあ二十五 六歳でしょう
博士号を取っていったならばね
これで六十 七十になってくると
やっぱり辞めなくちゃいけないし
ゾウガメはそのまま まだそのまま
で 生まれてきたゾウガメには番号を振ってちゃんとありますからね
やがて死んだらわかるでしょうね
将来 ハリエットを見て
いや すぐに女の子でしょうかね
ハリエット名前つけてるんだから
観察する範囲によって実体論も異なるんです
難しいんだから ちょこちょこと省きます
魂は有限 無限 突然現れる
死後無になる ある時間続くなどのたくさん説があります
で 皆様 西洋の哲学で知っているのは
魂は永遠なり それだけでしょ
貧困ですね 思考は インドのブッダの時代の哲学を見ると
魂は永遠というものもある
魂は空間的に無限という人もいるし
時間的に無限という人もいるし
魂の大きさは無限 有限
魂の寿命は有限 無限 あるいは魂はあるんだけど
死んだらきれいさっぱり消えるぞという人もいる
あるいは魂はあるんだけど
何回 何回 何回 何回生まれ変わりを続けた
それでまあエネルギー尽きて亡くなるという
いろいろ説はあるんです
すごいたくさんあります
まあぐらいかな 長部経典のナンバーワンのナンバーワンの今日は人間に観察できるすべての思考を六十二に集約してみたんですね
この六十二でお釈迦様が言うんですよ
人間に考えられるすべて入ってますよと
すごい断言ですよ すべて
これから人間も何考えたっても
この六十二のどちらかにはめるんだよと
これには名前はブラフマジャーラというんですよ
いわゆるすべてをまとめるネット
網 難しいんですだから
論は不完全な場合は異論
反論が成り立つんですよ
これ イスラムの方々に教えてあげたいんですけどね
異論があるということは
自分の論は不完全ということなんです
例えば地球が丸いということの異論はないでしょ
完全だから正しいんだからなんです
すべてを知る方法はこれではありません
こんなもんでは一切知ることはできません
ということですよ お釈迦様が言いたがっているのは
ただ 超能力があって 本当に過去を見えたってもね
知っても知ってもどうなるかと
知っても知っても切りがないでしょ
時空で考えると 一切を知ることは不可能です
知ったものは正しいと言えない
他人が別な観察で違う意見を出すから
自分の意見が間違いということになるんですよ
私はある空間を観察して何か言ったら
別の人 別な空間を考えて別なことを言うでしょうね
だからもう正しいということになりませんよ
例が出ますからね わかりやすい
しかし 他人の意見も別なデータさえあれば間違いになる可能性がある
相手の考え方もまた間違い変わったりするしね
科学ではよく見える現象ですよ
知る世界では正しい真理ということはありえない
これこれはある一部の結論
知る世界 知識世界では正しいということはないんです
真理ということはないんです
だから喧嘩する必要はないんですよ
どうせいい加減な知識なんですよ
歴史であろうか何であろう
例えば日本の日本の子供たちに教える日本の歴史は間違っていると中国人がすごく腹が立っている
中国人が中国人の好みで中国の子供たちに日本の歴史を教えているし
どちらでもいい加減ですよ
そんなものに喧嘩するなよということを言いたいんですよ
明らかに日本の歴史も間違っている
これは知識だからね 明らかに向こうの教えてくれることは間違っているんです
だから知識知識で言ったっても
結局は正しくない知識ばっかりでね
喧嘩するのかと だから仏教でそんなのはありえないんだから落ち着きなさいよと
知れば知るほど迷惑 知ることことで心が汚れる
高慢 怒り 嫉妬などが現れる
例えば皆様でもね 中国の子供たちは何勉強していますか？日本に対して何知っていますか？と聞いたら
かなり腹が立つと思いますよ
すごい厳しいことを教えられているみたいし
だから知ったら迷惑ですよ
中国人っていいなと思っているのにね
私 私見に愛着を感じる
執着する 頭が硬くなって他の知識を遮断する
ちょこちょこと知っちゃうと愛着が出てきて頭が硬くなっちゃうんです
それからもう人の話は聞き入れなくなっちゃうんです
悩みが増えるんですよ
欲は定着するんです 死ぬ時でも不満で苦しみで死ぬんです
宗教の世界が宣伝する最終的な安らぎと
と反対の方向へ進むんです
安らぎへ行くんじゃなくて
苦しみ 悩みへ進んでいくんですよ
どんな宗教でも安らぎの境地のことは謳ってはいるんだけど
やり方が苦しみ 戦争の道なんです
要するに苦しみが増える道なのです
知る世界は どのように知ったのかと
これからものすごい また変わります
六十二の宗教家にすべて釈尊がこのように結論を出すんです
まあ六十二で一切の知識
哲学 宗教をまとめちゃったんです
まとめてから結論出すんです
テーサン ババタン サマナ
ブラーマナナン アジャナタン
アパスタタン ヴェーダイタン
タンハアガタナン パリタッスシタ
ヴィッパンダンタム エーバ
と言ってもわからないんだからい
へへ このシャモンバラモンの方々に明確に知れなかった
見えなかったことです
よく明確に知れなかった
見えなかったよと だからすごい優しい心で言うんですよ
この このババタンということはすごい敬語なんですよ
だって真面目に修行したんだからね
まあ馬鹿にしてはいけませんよ
割愛に惹かれて 心の恐れ
揺らぎにより自分が感じたことです
で 割愛もあって それにやられちゃって
心は心に恐れ 揺らぎがあって
それでそうやって結論をさっさと出しちゃったんです
まあこれはまたこの直訳は難しいし
まあパーリブッダの言葉っていうのはあまりもコンパクトで
他の言語にすごく翻訳しにくいんですよ
その代わりにアラビア語よりはパーリ語っていうのはすごいシンプルで
誰にでも勉強できます
勉強するとパーリ語で直接理解することができます
で こちらで言うのは 彼らがせっかく何か発見しても
その知識によってまた心は恐怖になる
揺らいだりする ただぴパッサパッチアと
そこによるものですと
知ったのは 例えば 何か知ったと言っても
知っても それで恐怖感があって
心は揺らいだりする どのように知ったのかというと
そこによって知ったんです
そこっていうのは 感覚器官に情報対象が触れることです
我々には知る器官があるんですよ
知る器官に情報が触れるんですよ
情報が触れると知ったことになるんです
テーワタアンニャトラパッサパティサンパッサパティサンヴェディサンティティネータンターナンヴィッジャティ
意味は感覚に触れるという手段以外
別な手段で知ることはあり得ません
ありえないんだからね
感覚に情報触れなきゃ知らないんだから
な ちょっと間違った サッベーテーチェヒパッサヤタネヒプッサプッサパティサンヴェデンティ
全ての師匠は六所に触れては知る
触れては知るのです 触れては知る
触れては知る 触れては知る
例えば音楽を聴いてみてください
音楽っていうのはものすごい速さで
音というエネルギーがずっと触れて
触れる 触れる 触れる 触れては知る
触れては知る そこである一定の時間触れたところで
あ 音楽だ 歌だ 言葉だと理解するんです
もともと言葉ではありません
瞬間だけだったら 言葉でも音楽でも何でもないんです
それで触れては知って
触れては知って 触れては知って
まとめたら あ 歌ということになるんです
六処っていうのは 眼耳鼻舌身意という感覚器官
色声香味触法という対象が触れるのです
注意なんですけど そこっていうのは２つあります
この感覚器官に触れることにも触と言うんです
この体に触れることにも触と言うんです
その場合は派手ですよ
もう触るとわかりますからね
音は触れることはそんなに派手じゃないんですね
テーサンヴェーダナパッチャータンナ
そのそこから その感覚から渇愛が生まれるんですよ
彼らが触れたことは触れたものを感じるでしょう
感じたら渇愛が生まれてくるんです
やっぱり避けられませんよ
ちょこっとちょこっとした瞑想したことで
体のなんか重さや軽さや苦しさが消えちゃうと
それは感覚ですよ えらく舞い上がっちゃうんですよ
あ やった そう 私の瞑想成功したんでしょうねと私に聞くんですよ
だから私は何とも言えなくなっちゃうんですよ
強引で あまりも狂暴だったら何も言えない
それでその人のやっぱりすごい尊重しますよ
まあこんな感じもあったそうと
あまり欲張らないで言うと
次のステップは説明できるのに
やっぱり人間っていうのはそういうことで
何か感じたら すっごく欲が生まれてきます
まして過去を見られたならば
えらく欲が渇愛 欲が生まれますよ
タンハーパッチャーウパーダーナン
ウパーダーナパッチャーバホバハパッチャージャーティ
渇愛により固執が生じる
固執により存在を生じうる
うにより生再生 生まれることがあるんだと
渇愛があると まあ固執して知ったものに
それで業が生まれてきて
エネルギーが溜まっちゃって
精神的に それでどこかで生まれ変わっちゃう
ジャーティパッチャージャラーマラナン
ソーカパリデヴァドゥッカドーマナッスパイアーササンバヴァンティ
エオメータサケーワラスドゥッカカンダササムディヨホーティ
ショーによりローシ読めない
愛愁でしたっけ？え 浮腫
苦悩み 次はとにかく問が現れる
このように一切の苦しみ
体制が現れますよと では知ってください
何でもかんでも 何でもかんでも知るということはこんなもんだよと
とことん苦しみの循環が生まれますよというのはブッダの結論なんです
そういうところ 文章は一応馴染みがあると思いますけどね
知っても無知ですからね
それでおかしいですよ
なんで知りたがるのかというと
苦しいんだからなんですよ
だって無知はダメでしょ
学校に行って勉強しなかったら苦しいでしょ
人と喋れなくなったら苦しいでしょうね
だから苦しみをなくそうと思って知識得るんだけど
結果としては苦しみを得るんです
そこでえらい矛盾というか
循環 悪循環が生じています
一般知識人には想像もつかないほど超越した能力で
生命と宇宙のことを知っても
釈尊は知ることは衝動
知ることの衝動になったものになった元の苦しみに戻っていることを示すんです
だから なんでインドの宗教家たちが出家して修行したんですかね
生きることは苦しいんだからなんです
それで安らぎを欲しがったんです
そこですごいことを知ってしまったんです
それに執着するんです
執着すると もうそれから業がまた現れてきて
また生まれちゃうんです
それでまた生老病死で悩まなくちゃいけないんです
何やってるのかと だから元の衝動にまた戻ってますよ
要するに 知っても知っても無知無明なのです
知る道は智慧の道 幸福
安らぎの道ではありません
この循環から脱出できません
知るだけでは 知る道はおかしい
人間 まあこれ例えば例なんですよ
人間は食を取るんですね
いわゆる食は料理ということにしますね
料理はたくさん知った方がありがたいでしょ
では 過去 現在 将来にわたって現れる一切の料理のことを知りますかね
料理二つしか知らないと言ってるとかわいそうですね
四つ知ってるんだったら結構かっこいいしね
レパートリーが百二百ぐらい料理できればね
結構褒めてくれるしね
それだったら 過去現在
未来に現れるすべての料理の方法を知ったら一番かっこいいでしょ
世界一 でも知れますかと
ます不可能です 知っても役に立つのは現在
具体的に作ることができる料理だけでしょう
過去でローマ時代で人間はこういう料理を食べていた
縄文時代で料理 こういう風な料理して食べていた
今更知ったっても作れないでしょうに
将来はこういう料理作るんだぞとか
今更分かったっても 今役に立つのはマーケットで売ってるスーパーで売ってる野菜を持ってきて
自分にできる料理なんですよ
だからそのある程度で知ればいいんでしょうに
例えばもう一つ例 チキンを食べるからといって
チキンでできるすべての料理を知るとは成り立たないんですよ
みんな知りたがるのはデータではなく
データを組み立てた現象なんですよ
例えばチキンはデータですよ
テレビ見てください いろんなチャネルで
もうフランス料理を教えてくれるわ
ドイツ料理教えてくれるわ
アメリカ料理 中華料理
あれやこれやとかね チキンでしょうに
使っているのは チキンはデータ組み合わせたところで料理
我々それ知りたいんですよ
データじゃなくて現象を知りたいんですよ
だからキリがなくなっちゃうんです
データだったらほんのちょっとしかないんです
どうせ人間食べるものは何だといっても
そんなわずかでしょうに
チキン食べるは 豚食べるは
もうまた鳥たち 他のいくつかでしょうに
それは無限にあるし 知っても役に立たないんですよ
組み立てたら無限に組み立てますよ
あのレゴを持ってきたら
いくらでも組み立てますよ
ドミノでもね どんな方法でも組み立てますよ
それで基本だけ覚えておけばいいでしょ？誰にできますかね？ドミノで組み立てた建てられるすべてのシステムやって知ってやるぞと
ありえないでしょう それは決してありえない
バカバカらしい おかしい
ドミノ こんな形で倒したら
触れたら倒れる それで十分です
それから自分の能力でもいろいろやることですよ
百科事典を暗記しても
すべてを知ることになりません
なぜならば 百科事典というのは現象の集まりでしょ
だから百科事典を暗記すること
すごいかっこいいと思っているんです
それで一部一部データではなくて
合成したものを知っているだけで
しかし情報変わるんだからね
新しい本で出ますでしょ
また新しい百科事典を暗記しなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんで
現象ではなく現象のからくり
因果関係を知ると知る
知ったことになる 例っていうのは科学ですよ
科学っていうのはまず因果関係
からくりを発見するんですよ
それからいろいろ組み立てたり
自由自在に遊んだりする
例えば あの 今もできてないんだけど
磁石だったらもっと早く行くんじゃないかなと
リニアモーターですか
そういう法則をまず発見する
発見して 小さなモデルで走らせてみる
結構スピードで よかった
それから現象化するんですよ
人間に乗れるリニアモーターカー開発しようと
もうもうほとんどできてますけど
まだまだずっと研究しているんです
まだ一般人に使えるまではいってないんで
随分時間経ってますけど
しかし からくりは知っている
法則は知っている 問題はいかに現象化するのかっていうことなんです
だから現象の世界っていうのはそんなもんでね
キリがないんです 科学ではよくやってますから
科学には進歩があるんですね
で 正しくする真理を知るということ
ですから 必要なのは正しく知ることと真理を知ること
もうちょこっと言った
法則を発見しようよと
からくりを発見しようよと
現象じゃない 例えば 目に見えるすべてを知るっていうのはバカバカらしい
見えるからくりを発見する
それだったら 世の中で見えるもの全て見なくたってもいいんです
正しく知りたい人は法則を発見する
例 ウイルスによって病気になるとは法則の一つでしょ
病気になる原因の一つはウイルスですね
しかし 一切のウイルスとそれによって生まれる一切の病気を知ることは不可能です
医学者はそれやりません
でもウイルスは知ってます
それで鳥インフルエンザウイルスあるでしょうに
これ新しいウイルスだからね
それで人間に感染したらどうしようかとわからない
ワクチンはできてない
これから作るんです だから科学者は全部知っていると言えますよ
なぜならば ウイルスとウイルスは体に攻撃して病気に病気を作ると
しかし ウイルスはどちらに攻撃するかっていうことははっきりはしないんですね
ウイルスによって肺をやられるか
腸をやられるか 心臓に行くか
神経に行くか 脳細胞を壊してそこを壊れるか分からない
で それ発見してからもうワクチン作って
それから治療する だから法則だけ知っておけば十分です
ブッダは現象を知る道は間違いだと知って
法則を発見することにしたのです
前も出た経典は法則ですね
因果法則 法則を発見した人こそが一切智者なのです
ブッダはサッブヴィドゥ
一切智者です お釈迦様が一切智者なんです
質問したら答えます ある人がね
驚いちゃって あんたってすごいと
質問された途端 見事に明確に順番で段取りで
例えば話まで持って見事に結論を出して答えるんだと
あの 聞きたいんだけど
お釈迦様が一人でいると
このように質問すると
このように答える このように質問すると
このように答えると準備しますかと
知らんでしょ 人はどんな質問するかっていうことは
そんな準備しませんよと
私は法則を知ってますよと
法則を知ってるんだからね
あなたはね 質問すると途端
そこに答えがあるんだよと
完璧な答え だから一切智者なんです
また見えなくなっちゃった
フフ